[Musique]
c'est lui intégra nous sommes le 5
septembre
je sors du métro et qui se croisent
c'est moi et oui on va travailler là où
on va voir à la conférence de rentrée
d'une chaîne qui s'appelle bfm tv vous
la connaissez tous
ouais et là il va y avoir beaucoup de
questions sur la coupure du signal
barange à mon avis complet par free
s'était coupé par orange
on va leur causer un max de questions et
on va voir ce qu'il nous dise moi j'ai
hâte de voir changé pour toi tu penses
qu'il sera là petit retour ça y est avec
mes amours gbagbo n'est pas parce que je
n'ai pas de rien vous voyez et là vous
voyez ma fille chez g ou regardez comme
ils sont doués et talentueux
voilà ils sont beaux ces la reprise ya
benjamin castaldi derrière au secours
chérissez bientôt sa commande en
quelques minutes est ce que vous êtes
prêts
voilà voilà voilà voilà
regardez sa fonction des enjeux
nationaux supporter à la dream team à
des crocs et donc comme en image un son
pas ça n'a pas de sens mais quand tu
t'assois tu peux t'asseoir
iranien
wouah
[Musique]
jours
ah ah ah
oh
[Musique]
va est terrible et des ouf
je suis très bons les audois je tape les
autres héros à mesure ils pas mis
longtemps j'étais encore une fois plus
au dessus du lot mais moi les séries
dans l'habitude puis voilà mais ça va
être lancée pour le reste mais une
première du tpm pc ça un public qui
attend fébrile comme nous une scène et
un barnum tout autour voilà c'est du
boulot hein y'a pas que les chroniqueurs
qui bossent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
tél
[Rires]
[Musique]
toujours aussi c'est ça qu'on aime
regarde les amis qui se retrouvent ce
soir donc fort boyard sur france 2
[Musique]